nobody wants to queue for a food bank at
any stage of their lives
but imagine like brenda having to do it
at the age of 78 with the ability to
earn long gone
or 68 year old michael who's worked all
his life on the london underground and
says he has 25 pounds a week in spare
cash
you imagine that life would be like this
no
no not at all i thought i was going to
live comfortably
what i have to do is boil water every
time i want to shave or
have the proper voice
the food bank can trigger a range of
emotions
are you struggling
too much
one in five pensioners are in poverty
and after two years and counting of a
pandemic which picks off the most frail
amongst the elderly the cost of living
adds to their loneliness and anxiety
i think it goes back to their
experiences often of being brought up in
in wartime and and the the experience of
there not being enough to go around and
having to
you know to make do
time and again people are turning to
their communities these are volunteers
brought together by unprecedented need
in extraordinary
their first call is to a 92 year old man
who hasn't been out since last october
richard needs the lights on all day
because his flat is so dark his oxygen
machine runs constantly it's all racking
up energy costs
hello my friend how you keeping the
volunteers have brought him food and
company
we're isolated now from the rest of the
community in within that within our own
building
next there's a book to deliver to dory
oh there's a that that's a cape site at
74 she can't afford to put the central
heating on instead there's one bar of
the electric fire on in one room
the other night i went to bed and i felt
lovely
and then about two o'clock in the
morning
the eating i've left the eating on so
i've had to come all the way down on the
stair lift
to turn the eating off and then you wake
up
freezing cold
do you find it all quite depressing
yeah yeah
it is
and it's getting even worse now
what's worrying is the long-term impact
on the elderly
a lot of people because of the poverty
that they face
will lead to premature earlier deaths
because of them not being able to feed
themselves or clot themselves or keep
themselves warm adequately
living in fear of poverty for an
increasing number of pensioners what
should be their golden years have lost
their sparkle lisa holland sky news east
london